talk a little bit about that specific
sentence right so market participants
can source on-chain data to analyze
bitcoin in more depth than is possible
with any other traditional asset sounds
like a big statement i tend to agree
with you but elaborate a little bit it
absolutely is but i i believe it is true
and i think that goes back to the nature
of you know what these assets represent
and what they are at their core uh so
first off when you think about you know
an institutional investor's approach to
gaining exposure to different asset
classes they always want some sort of
fundamental framework now the there are
some sort of framework to analyze
fundamentals now the interesting thing
is that bitcoin doesn't really fit in
the framework of traditional asset
classes
and so because it doesn't they
automatically assume
that uh it it's impossible to analyze
fundamentals because it doesn't have any
fundamentals when in reality if you look
at what they are at their core right
these public blockchains they're they're
auditable they're open they're
transparent software
which means that today anyone can pretty
much
download a bitcoin client install a node
and extract insightful network data with
pretty much no barriers country
the analogy that we give in the piece is
that you know the same way that a
government statistical agency might
publish data about a country's
population or economy or a public
company is going to publish quarterly
financial statements disclosing growth
rates and earnings bitcoin and by
extension public blockchains provide
this real-time global ledger that
publishes data about the network's
activity and inner economics and so
anyone at any time can go and really
understand you know buyer and seller
behavior long-term fundamentals and see
you know where where uh where the market
is at any given time you've got a
section in the report that says
assessing the health of the bitcoin
network and we have this table
where you basically break down okay if
we're gonna assess the health of the uh
bitcoin network there's kind of three
ways that you cut it you cut it by
monetary integrity you cut it by
security and you cut it by usage and so
talk us through kind of why are these
three uh pieces um the three kind of
aspects or cuts that you look at when
you evaluate that layer one of assessing
the health of the bitcoin network like
why these three sure so i think i think
it goes back to
the core of what what bitcoin is as a
you know
non-sovereign monetary system you know
when people talk about what bitcoin's
value proposition is it's not you know
all the bells and whistles that bitcoin
has to offer it's the fact that it's
really competing as a global based money
in a decentralized way and so the the
paradigm or the mental model that needs
to be adopted when analyzing the
fundamentals of the bitcoin network i
think should resemble how you'd analyze
something that's how you'd analyze a
monetary system
so first and foremost is around monetary
integrity i think the reason why bitcoin
distinguishes itself as a monetary asset
relative to other public blockchains is
the predictability in its monetary
policy uh this i i believe that at least
what bitcoin is competing on isn't a
monetary revolution not a technological
revolution and as such being able to you
know not only verify your holdings at
any given time but then verify uh this
total circulating supply uh is a
fundamental feature in in bitcoin uh and
and if it were to break would it would
ultimately uh you know not bode well for
its underlying fundamentals uh now how
does monetary integrity remain intact
well you need to have a secure and
robust chain uh that that where the
economic incentives are are
are well aligned uh and so you know when
you think about specifically uh the
dynamics between miners uh and you know
and nodes and developers users uh you
know making sure that that that the the
the network is being secured as designed
is is again a fundamental um yes it's
fundamental to understanding the health
of the network uh so you know i'd say
on a weekly basis we go through these
on-chain metrics just because we we
manage around some of the volatility and
uh and the most recent sort of metric on
hash rate where we've seen a full
recovery
if you don't count yesterday's uh drop
off from the kazakhstan internet
shutdown uh since like basically china's
migration or
hash rate migration out of china um so
the ability for bitcoin to recover
within six months uh the hash rate
levels and effectively put to bed that
china controls the bitcoin narrative uh
is is is really important to
understanding and having high conviction
of long-term fundamentals and then
finally around usage it's really
thinking about you know the bitcoin is
being used as this you know global
settlement network uh that active
addresses are hovering between 800 000
to a million at any given time that
transaction volume this year i think
adjusted transaction volume we've seen
13 trillion dollars
worth of volume settled which exceeds
now visas total transaction volume and
is uh you know
within an order of magnitude of the fed
wire
so there's you know a lot of interesting
and compelling data points uh that
allows us to assess the long-term
fundamentals but that won't necessarily
inform us on you know what price is
going to do